As your applications grow in complexity
how do you harness and drive new
insights from all the chaos? And is
observability just a buzzword, or is it
something that you actually need to
think about? Spoiler alert, it is. My name
is Sai Vennam and I'm with the IBM Cloud
team, and today I'm joined with a special
guest. Hi there, I'm Laura Santamaría and
I am a Developer Advocate with LogDNA.
If you don't know LogDNA is a core part
of our observability story on IBM Cloud,
but today we're gonna be talking about
observability, so let's start with
definition. So observability is a
property of your systems that helps you
understand what's going on with them,
monitor what they're doing, and be able
to get the information you need to
troubleshoot. So the way we see it
there's three major tears of
observability and let's go through those now.
We're gonna start out with my favorite
which is logging. In addition to logging
we additionally have metrics, so that's
just all of your analytics around all of
the data that you're gathering and
finally...we've got monitoring. Now
monitoring is essentially putting up a
magnifying glass to your systems and
getting new insights from what's
actually running there. Today we're gonna
be starting with an example,
in the
bottom left corner we have sketched out
a few of the different infrastructure
pieces so we'll start with today. Can we
explain what those are? Sure, we have a
public cloud, it can be any of them. And then
you have on-prem, and then let's say we
actually have some user data, maybe this
is a tablet or a cell phone. So all of
those infrastructure pieces are creating
and generating data and what I'm kind of
gonna focus on here is the personas that
are going to consume them. So we've got
that Dev persona,
we've got Ops,
and finally we have Security. So, all of
this data flowing in is kind of a lot, I
want to have some way of filtering it
down for my specific user personas to be
able to understand it. So let's start
with developers,
what do developers care about? I actually
want to back up here for a moment though
because let's talk about all the
different levels that logging can come
from. So we have three different levels
that we can think about so you have your
Operating System, you have Kubernetes or
any other type of platform, so I'm
picking kubernetes. That's my favorite. And
then finally your application. So your
operating system and kubernetes all send
really good logs and you can use a lot
of that data pretty much as this, or add
in some of your own but applications is
really where you need to spend some time.
So you're devs need to create a proper
event stream and this really goes by the
garbage in, garbage out system where you
really need to put in good work and get
some good data on the side of the
application so that you get good logs
out. Right, exactly, so the great
developers out there on kubernetes and
the operating Systems they've
instrumented their platforms but the
application that's up to you as a
developer to make sure the
instrumentation is in place. Absolutely,
and when you think about it, let's say
that we have an operating system here
and I'm gonna say that's an operating
system, and then we have kubernetes
running on it. And then you actually have
your app running on top of kubernetes.
And all of these are to each sending
data. So we have three different levels
of data all coming out and trying to
come towards the dev that wants some
information. Right, so it looks like
they're all coming into this central
area here. That's right. We can talk about
this is our aggregator.
So our aggregator takes in all of this
data and puts it all into one place so
we can work with it. That's right, but
kind of
coming back to the the problem here a
developer might not care about all of
the information flowing in, how do we
drive just the pieces that they care
about like we mentioned? Maybe they
instrumented their specific application,
how do we drive that to them? Absolutely,
so an aggregator often has filters. So in
this case let's say the dev is just
asking for data about debugging and just
some information there, and your data,
your filter can actually set up a
dashboard or some other way of accessing
all of that data that the dev can take a
look at just the pieces that they need.
That's a core part of a observability
solution, this aggregator not only does
it collect the data but it needs to
externalize it, expose it, so my
developers can access it and drive new
insights. So let's say we solved that
part of the puzzle,
what do operators care about? What are
the operations teams? What are they
looking for out of these systems? So an
operations team might need to know more
about degradation of its system, or if a
pod is falling over,  maybe your database
filled up and you need to know more
information about how you can fix it.
The ops teams is going to be getting
data from all of these different systems
and filtering it out to yet another
dashboard or another interface of some
sort and getting that data just what
they need. Right, so potentially they may
not care as much about specific
application level logs but they'll be
looking to kubernetes to say hey what
was the CPU usage, do we need to set up
some horizontal pod auto scalers to make
sure that we don't hit those limits.
Finally, kind of probably see where I'm
going here with the last piece of the
puzzle with security, they probably have
a dashboard that's created for them as
well. So a security team let's say
they're using a third-party tool as most
security teams generally, do they
identify a threat ID, or maybe a customer
ID and they want to dive in deeper to a
potential threat that's been identified.
So they put that information in the
aggregator and they can identify and
make kind of sense of all the chaos to
identify exactly what that specific
security analyst might be looking for.
But I want to pose an interesting
question here, it's not always about
going to the system and identifying
what's there,
many times security advisors need to
know what's happening the second it
happens and they can't just sit there
and stare at logs all day, right.
Absolutely, this is where monitoring
comes in, this is really a two-way street.
We have automated alerts that can go out
and tell all of these different groups
about specific things that they're
interested in, specific events that they
want to know about. So let's say that you
have a system that's been accessed and
it's not supposed to be frankly that
system is going to figure it out long
before a human is and that's what an
alert is for an ops team doesn't want to
find out that there's a degradation of
service when their user does, they need
to know ahead of time. So a good
observability solution should have the
ability to externalize the data and then
additionally set up a learning on top of
that. So our dev team may be their most
comfortable in Slack, so they set up a
chat bot so that particular exceptions
when they're thrown they're able to know
when they happen. Your ops team may be
they were using something like a paging
system so that you know in the middle of
the night if something goes down they
get alert and they can start looking
into it right away. And then finally for
our security teams, kind of as I
mentioned, they're generally using you
know maybe third party tools or custom
dashboards they can set up custom
alerting so they can know exactly when
something goes down. And to be honest
this is your new norm, you're going to
have multiple clouds, you're going to
have on-premise systems, you're going to
have data coming directly in from your
users. You need to be able to understand
what's going on and really this is what
observability is all about. Thanks for
joining us for this quick overview of
observability, also thank you so much for
joining us today Laura. Absolutely, my
pleasure. If you have any questions
please drop us a line below. If you want
to see more videos like this in the
future, please like and subscribe. And
don't forget you can always get started
on the cloud at no cost by signing up
for a free IBM Cloud account.